yes this is in World Forum economy here
it's very nice for me for knowledge
because already it's a it's already this
is the procession here is about new
visions and invasion it's a very
important for economic old economy and
this is like example our our country is
in Egypt it's already every you should
start in 25 of January and SS after that
people it's already feeling this better
and all genuine Babel it's the age from
20 to 30 years if the people it's
already own to New Egypt New Egypt need
the first innovation you need second
it's a it's a will education and number
three it's already the small company and
middle company and already Egypt before
before nineteen eighty it's already the
education in Egypt was is a very nice
and Egypt is coverage all Labor's in in
in Middle East and aberrant country and
now 30 years Egypt without any any any
any good sign and this is a general new
generation it's in Egypt it will be a
change a lot in the education in the in
the in the health side and in the in the
economic because already we did the last
last two weeks about the big seminar
about with how the Egypt after
elections in next september's a how the
Egypt it will be better we make short a
strategy and long strategy and this is
we that lost last week is a big seminar
about a new economy in Egypt and this is
I think it's a gypped few years not now
but few years minimum it's two or three
years and I think that Egypt life it
would be better thank